à
[Musique]
bonjour à tous on est déjà au mois de
mai bienvenue dans ce iront parler sport
l'émission à ne pas manquer si vous êtes
un amoureux un passionné de sport local
et de sport évinois aujourd'hui au
programme comme toujours une dose de
bonne humeur des analyses sportives très
poussé surtout des coups de gueule et
des débats nos chroniqueurs sont avec
moi en plateau ou via écran interposé
pour s'exprimer sur cette actualité
sportive évinoise à présentation on
commence tout de suite par la personne
qui va m'accompagner sur ce plateau j'ai
une chance incroyable de l'avoir à mes
côtés à chaque émission
si vous ne le connaissez pas encore vous
n'allez pas être déçus les connais tous
surtout l'italienne lover gregory kane
années il est avec nous pendant les
locales bonjour à toutes et à tous
comment allez vous m'écoutez très bien
de bonnes nouvelles en perspective on va
en parler tout à l'heure pour le sport
et le sport local et je me suis pas
encore remis tout à fait des petites
surprises que vous m'avez réservé lors
de la dernière émission d'ailleurs merci
encore c'était un grand moment de
télévision
oui je rappelle qu'on avait fêté votre
anniversaire ici assure sur ce plateau
en tout cas j'espère vous l'avez bien
fêter le soir même on l'a bien fait très
bon parfait c'est une bonne nouvelle on
continue par un monument de cette
émission musique
il nous a énormément manqué lors de la
dernière émission c'est un véritable
pilier invoque qui nous vient tout droit
du rugby-club de versailles le
gladiateur pierre chevalier est avec
nous pendant une heure bonjour pierre à
lui michael salut les amis vous m'avez
lu terriblement manqué aussi la dernière
fois vous avez manqué également
bah oui pour des raisons un petit peu
funès en plus j'ai loupé le j'ai loupé
de l'anniversaire de notre italienne
glover et je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
passaient une dizaine mais c'est pas du
tout la même
on dira pas votre âge à un pierre
chevalier paraissant trop lourd lui de
retour parmi nous musique c'est un
joueur de basket exceptionnel il a
notamment joué à monaco ou encore en
espagne il a côtoyé les plus grands
comme tony parker il joue aujourd'hui
attrapé en équipe nationale avec la
république centrafricaine mr mike mont
korhogo nous fait le plaisir d'être avec
nous bonjour tout le mois comment savez
vous comment allez vous ça va ça va bien
merci
vous avez bien réviser les missions vous
avez vu les thématiques vous êtes au top
oui ça va je suis prêt et je ne suis pas
trop de paris se dédire soir n'en dit
pas quoi on en parlera juste après un
dandy de patrons alors on a regardé le
meilleur pour la fin
musique c'est notre superstar on a du
mal à le garder dans cette émission
à chaque enregistrement ses agents nous
demande de plus en plus d'argent je vous
annonce si on continue comme ça on va
fermer la chaîne le monument
l'incroyable genlis ex-entraîneur de
plaisir est avec nous un jour jean
bonjour à tous
d'après plusieurs de vos alors vos 5 1
gens nous demandent de plus en plus
d'argent d'argent comment on fait on est
avec vous quand même je ne sais pas si
monsieur guy gobbato ouais ok bon on en
parlera après l'émission
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission nous allons parler de walid
mesloub l'ancien footballeur de lorient
et lens a été mise en examen pour recel
de blanchiment de drogue
le joueur originaire de trappes
aujourd'hui âgé de 35 ans est soupçonné
d'avoir des liens avec l'homme présenté
comme la tête du sdf du réseau surnommé
le chinois cet homme aurait notamment
utilisé des voitures immatriculées au
nom du footballeur ainsi que l'un de ses
comptes bancaires à son insu son avocat
affirme que walid mesloub ignorait tout
des activités du trafiquant présumé est
ce que cette histoire peut salir sa
belle carrière
c'était un bon joueur il a notamment
joué à versailles wav à lorient a lancé
en sélection nationale algérienne il a
été lui d'ailleurs meilleur joueur de
l'année 2010 8 du racing club de lens
est ce que cette histoire peut salir sa
belle carrière oui vous êtes partagés
partager
baigorri partager également mike petits
pouces mais ça peut servir sa carrière
du coup pour vous c'est toujours délicat
de pister genre de situation là je suis
en tout cas on sait que c'est un joueur
qui est quand même assez médiatisé donc
c'est des choses qui peut prendre des
proportions démesurées
après maintenant est-ce que c'était vrai
dans cette histoire rassemblement ne
sais quoi alors je vais vous donné par
les grecs vous avez peut-être un peu
plus de dormir
c'est pour ça que moi je suis partagé
effectivement s'il est prouvé s'il est
condamné parce que pendant c'est une
mise en examen il ya toujours cette
question de la présomption d'innocence
donc pour le moment
attendons de voir ce qu'il est dit est
ce que le tribunal va dire tant qu'il
n'est pas condamné à mon sens il ya la
présomption d'innocence
effectivement s'il est condamné ça va
c'est à dire sa carrière il a une belle
carrière il a été champion national
meilleur joueur de lens en ligue 2 il a
fait trois saisons en ligue 1 du côté de
lorient donc une belle carrière
maintenant voilà lui se défend il dit
qu'il a été plutôt instrumentalisée dans
cette affaire qui n'était pas au courant
des agissements vous avez parlé de 2,7
personnes surnommées le chinois donc
pour le moment j'attends que toute la
lumière soit faite sur la faire donc
c'est pour ça que je reste partagé tant
que et la justice ne l'a pas condamné
officiellement pour le moment ça a pas
sali sa carrière après c'est sûr que et
bien c'est une petite tache qui devra
laver qui devra laver dans les juger
devant la justice pierre chevalier
oui je suis d'accord d'accord avec avec
greg
je dirais plutôt oui parce qu'à partir
du moment où ça sort
c'est une c'est une tache sur le sur le
cv du sur le cv du sportif maintenant
c'est vrai qu'on est au tout début je
pense que l'anc est l' enquête vient
d'être lancé il faudra faire la lumière
comme comme daigle a indiqué avant de
savoir quelles sont ces responsabilités
là dedans s'il est coupable ou pas de
quelques mots les agissements que ce
choix là où je dis que ça peut ça peut
empêcher sa carrière c'est à partir du
moment où ça sort dans la presse et
jusqu'à une
donc chaînes comme tv 78 30 ans sur ce
plateau c'est pas vraiment du sport mais
tant pis ça entache rattachera un petit
peu au moins sa réputation il faudra
qu'ils se disent on défende
d'ici là d'ici là il y aura quand même
quelques quelques articles et quelques
suspicions qui ont été jean qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais voilà c'est ce
que pierre pire a dit ce que je voulais
dire
je pense que toute façon condamné ou pas
il le traînera et jusqu'à la fin de sa
carrière maintenant il aura ses tics est
là malheureusement dû bien mal au ventre
et ça arrive quand même jean à la fin de
sa carrière finalement il a il ya 35 ans
à 7,2 pour ça il cherchait une
reconversion
non c'était c'était bien avant les faits
qui est bien avant mais préparer sa
reconversion d'ailleurs on l'a vu des
photos il avait de la poudre sur la tête
non alors petit carton jaune pour
commencer un jean attention j'ai
commencé fort pour moi roy de toute
façon malheureusement ce genre de faire
qu'à 55 ans sont comme ça au grand jour
malheureusement il va pouvoir se défaire
et viaur si par contre il reconnu
coupable à la paix
on a vu que dans d'autres affaires par
exemple benzema le jugement définitif
n'a pas été encore rendu il doit encore
comparaître devant la cour de versailles
on a vu que ça le suivait jusqu'à
maintenant les faits se sont déroulés il
ya plusieurs années encore aujourd'hui
il n'est toujours pas sélectionné en
équipe de france donc c'est vrai que ça
peut entacher maintenant moi j'attends
de voir quand même ce que va dire la
justice sur cette affaire
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de basket libinois de 17
ans victor o m.ban yama crève l'écran
avec nanterre est il déjà une star nous
allons tenter de répondre à cette
question coup de projecteur également
sur l'annulation de la course à pied
paris-versailles programmée en septembre
prochain
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler football
on va tout de suite parlé de ce match de
ligue des champions entre le psg et
manchester city laventure des parisiens
s'arrête au stade des demi finales de la
compétition les joueurs qui s'entraînent
au camp des loges à saint germain en
laye ont perdu au match aller au match
retour face au citizen 2-1 à l'aller 2 0
au retour
le psg ne remportera donc pas la ligue
des champions tant espérée depuis
l'arrivée des qataris dans la capitale
française
la question sur cette thématique le psg
est il finalement à sa place oui ou non
vous voter oui pour vous pierre
chevallier à tomber d'accord sur cette
thématique
on va peut-être commencer par vous
pierre vous a été le premier je pense
que je pense que cette année par rapport
aux par rapport aux parterres aux
équipes aux équipements et forces en
présence plus le contexte le contexte au
vide
et quand on regarde dans le rétro sur
les 4 dernières quatre ou cinq dernières
années en ligue des champions le psg
semble définitivement à sa place ce qui
est évidemment très dommageable pour les
peaux les fans et des supporters mais
sur un match comme celui d'hier un match
couperet aller retour l'équipe du psg à
exister a priori une mi temps sur les
sur les quatre sur les deux matchs sur
les deux matches concernés et avec une
contre une équipe de manchester city qui
semble vraiment elle dans son sujet et
dans sont dans une très belle année où
ils sont encore ils sont encore en
course pour je crois trois trophées sur
sur quatre à la fois sur uk et puis et
puis sur la ligue des champions il
malheureusement avec les aléas et des
blessures malgré l'effectif l'effectif
presque pléthorique parfois s'il est au
complet
le psg n'a pas réussi à inverser la
tendance finale l'année dernière donc on
va dire que dans le dernier carré le psg
le psg est à sa place qui est déjà une
place un petit peu honorifique finale
perdu l'année dernière
demi finales perdues cette année avec
avec beaucoup beaucoup de regrets je
pense sur la même d'abord ça se serait
passé les dernières petites choses c'est
pochettino aussi qui est arrivé sur la
pointe des pieds est assez récemment
tient pas encore l'équipe vraiment bien
en main tour elle qui est partie qui a
d'autres qui ad'autres destinée est lui
encore en course
donc oui avec ce dans le temps les huit
meilleures équipes européennes en ligue
des champions donc là en demi finale le
psg est à sa place genre qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
le pdp j'étais à sa place c'est-à-dire
demi finale de ligue des champions et
pas plus voilà tout à fait v aujourd'hui
ils ont pas prouvée alors l'an dernier
pour moi on a déjà parlé au moins y
avait une gueule un parcours assez à ces
facilités par le tirage au sort mais
c'est vrai que là cette année il avait
abattu deux belles pointures à
d'ailleurs le barcelone barcelone et le
bayern
donc on pouvait se dire on l'a et ils
ont ils ont scié les jambes fait le job
après quand même on voit sur le match et
sert sur les deux matches contre
manchester
malheureusement il aura quand même la
peinture supplémentaires ont figuré
parmi les très graves des équipes
pointures et liaison lapointe urgent
disons qu'elle en ait marre ils ont les
mêmes et c'est pas les moins durs nema
neymar et joue que pour lui c'est un
sangatte et s'efforce lui les images
quelques claques dans le baigneur et
pourquoi pas pour se mettre au service
du jeu allez l'entendre avait déjà un
carton jaune argent attention alors
c'est quoi non moi je suis entraîneur ou
chef de l'état
je veux dire non mais faut arrêter c'est
en compte pas on a vu hier géant vers
l'avant la pousse vers le matin hier
j'ai vu quoi j'ai vu une équipe une
équipe collective à travers manchester
qui s'est jamais affolé sur les deux
rencontres ils ont toujours joué leur
jeu ils ont toujours joué ils ont jamais
jamais douté de la première à la
dernière minute ils n'ont jamais douté
après faut pas écouter les commentaires
selon un de ses proches mais là on a une
équipe après et qui joue sur
les individualités qui jouent sur des
exploits bape et neymar mais neymar et
joue que pour lui c'est pas un collectif
qui joue pour sa cour pour lui donc
malheureusement
et puis et puis à son premier entraîneur
ça change trop souvent d'entraîneur pour
installer une continuité dans un
collectif
c'est pas possible on peut pas avoir un
collectif bien rôdé quand on change un
tueur ou les a c'est impossible donc
pour moi il sut pas leur place
mike je vous donne la parole ensuite ce
sera à vous des gorilles vous étiez très
énervé j'ai l'impression oui après je
suis mitigé par rapport au résultat de
paris parce que c'est vrai que nous ont
quand même une très belle équipe sur le
papier
après j'ai des doutes entre la direction
c'est-à-dire les dirigeants dirigeants
le coach coach
joueurs et dirigeants entre elles à la
joie
qu'est ce que je veux entendre par là
quand on a un joueur comme neymar qui
est le leader des groupes de cette
équipe là c'est à dire c'est quelqu'un
qui est censé rassurer ses coéquipiers
qui est censé les mettre en vente un
coût qui est censé faire les bonnes
décisions et que quand on voit qu à
chaque fois piqué ma revient dans cette
équipe de paris parce qu'il faut le
préciser démarche fois ça fait depuis
deux saisons maintenant il ouvre
énormément de matches et cette année en
l'occurrence ils ont gagné deux matches
importants contre le barça et le bayern
vinet maria était pas on le voit ce
n'est qu'en cette équipe et les cinémas
et les moins fortes c'est vrai mais elle
est plus collectif qu'à une notion de
deux de large front ensemble une gueule
magne et dkny marelli da on a
l'impression que qui joue un petit peu
pour sa foi ils y cherchent un marbrier
que pour lui et et c'est là où je parle
des entraîneurs et de part des
dirigeants
ils ont un rôle important à jouer par
rapport à ça parce qu'une inscription
comme le psg ne peut pas laisser des
joueurs comme neymar pourrait frapper au
dessus de l'institution quand on va
aller barré par nous le tas d'herbes ap
où on leur proposait un contrat déjà et
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui et sipa c'est
quelque part ça révèle un petit peu
l'organisation du paris saint germain
on a des clubs comme le bayern munich où
tu as des joueurs des grands joueurs
pour leur propose des contrats on leur
donne trois jours pour qu'ils signent le
contrat si signes comme peu importe nous
le joueur restait pas dans le cloud donc
on va bien qu'elle ait un petit souci
par rapport à ça
et donc voilà c'est en sache un peu
mitigés par rapport aux résultats du
paris saint germain
et puis après la dernière chance celle
ci a inventé savait très bien qu'il
n'était pas en bonne forme pour le match
aller il a quand même joué ce match là
donc peut-être qu'ils auraient pu avoir
une meilleure gestion peut-être le gérer
ne pas le faire du tout vrai pour ce
premier match là parce que cette douleur
au mollet l'avait déjà et ensuite le
faire jouer pour le deuxième match
donc voilà je le rappelle grégory c'est
à vous maintenant juste ajouter par
rapport à neymar oui ça je pense qu'on
est d'accord tous pour dire qu'il est
passé complètement à côté de ses deux
demi finales après sur la campagne de
ligue des champions je vous trouve quand
même un peu dur je trouve que cette
année il a apporté sur les autres
matches face au bayern c'est l'un des
meilleurs sur le match aller il a marqué
six buts sur cette campagne de
champion's league donc oui effectivement
on attend d'un joueur décisif et qui a
coûté ses 220 millions d'euros qui
viennent apporter qu'il soit décisif sur
les deux matches des demi finales il est
passé complètement à côté après moi je
trouve que au vu de sa campagne de ligue
des champions ça va cette année c'est
pas été le joueur le moins bon du côté
parisien
après c'est vrai neymar on relance le
débat on en a parlé dans cette émission
il a manqué quasiment la moitié des
matchs du paris saint-germain docu qu'il
a signée s'est en 2018 2010 est ce qu'il
est arrivé au paris saint germain est
donc oui on peut discuter effectivement
son vrai impact et sa vraie utilité au
sein du collectif parisien après moi
j'ai répondu oui pour le paris saint
germain et il a sa place oui pour moi le
paris saint germain et à la place qu'il
convient c'est à dire dans les quatre
cinq meilleures équipes actuellement en
europe
est ce que ça veut dire que le paris
saint germain n'a pas ni vos poils en
finale
non moi je me positionnerai pas sur ça
parce que à mon sens sur sur les demi
finales à ce stade de la compétition et
bien ça se joue à des détails qu'est-ce
qui est qu'est-ce qui me qu'est-ce qu'on
était les détails sur les deux demi
finales notamment le match aller où
paris saint germain fait une excellente
première mi temps et ça se joue à des
détails
navas qui a été énorme depuis le début
de la compétition qui fait une demie
erreur et le mur qui s'écarte sur le
coup franc de mares d'ailleurs maryse le
petit clin d'oeil aux aux petits
franciliens qui met trois buts face au
paris saint germain
donc je pense que ça joue à des détails
c'est vrai que sur le match retour paris
est passé complètement à côté manchester
city a fait preuve de cannes a vraiment
dominé paris de la tête et des épaules
sur le match retour
donc oui paris est à sa place ça ne veut
pas dire que dans les saisons prochaines
paris ne pourra pas aller en finale en
tout cas sa place aujourd'hui c'est les
quatre cinq meilleures équipes
européennes est-ce que c'était pas trop
aussi pour paris il ya huit défaites 1
on en avait parlé à grégory justement en
ligue 1 cinq défaites au total en ligue
des champions c'est peut-être trop
peut-être pour une équipe qui vise le
titre je pense que ça joue aussi à
manchester city d'un côté qui a
quasiment assuré le titre en premier
league qui a treize points d'avancé sur
manchester united qui avait pas
forcément on va dire la première league
en tête puisque on va dire le titre est
assurée à 96 97 % pour manchester city
en premier league et la situation est
totalement différente pour paris qui a
un seul point de retard sur lille qui
est pour le moment leader de 2,9 à trois
journées de la fin donc je pense que
paris est aussi tournée vers la liga
c'est peut-être qui a pu on va dire
monopolisé certaine force certaine aussi
penser peut-être que les parisiens
n'étaient pas totalement engagée elle
n'est pas totalement la tête dans ses
deux demi finales pierre chevalier il
faut rappeler là maintenant et il
constaté c'est que malheureusement sur
une sur une belle saison comme celle-là
qui est particulière mais qui est
particulière pour toutes les équipes se
sont dans le dans le en ligue 1 comme en
ligue des champions c'est qu'en gros
pari peut tout perdre
autant vous pouvez ce qu'on pouvait se
plaindre que sur les saisons précédentes
régi écrase la concurrence notamment
lire avec avec le fait d'enterrer le
suspense quasiment dès le début de la
saison mais là sur une saison où il ya
un petit peu plus de résistance en ligue
1 avec monaco avec lille
évidemment et avec eux et avec lyon il a
avec son élimination en ligue des
champions ce fameux point de retard que
rappeler que rappeler grec sur sur l'île
grosso modo le psg peut quasiment tout
perdre cette année ne rien les gars sont
les solutions du coup pour pour l'avenir
du psg genre est ce que vous en avez des
solutions est ce qu'il faut changer
d'entraîneur encore est-ce qu'il faut
enlever neymar est
dap et les deux je ne sais pas quelles
sont vos solutions j'entends ce que de
police qui avait vraiment une solution
miracle il sera assez gras il aurait
déjà brûlante or donc mais il est
certain que la juge ait un petit peu
tout à l'heure ne serait-ce qu on y voit
un entraîneur si on ne pérennise pas un
entraîneur et qu'on ne nous écoute pas
cet entraîneur et qu'on ne laisse pas
mettre en place un style de jeu avec des
automatismes parce que c'est avant tout
un sport collectif
si on le change constants un entraîneur
on n'aura jamais une équipe qui jouera
de la même manière et qui aura des
automatismes et ça vous moi c'est la
base après les joueurs les joueurs se
faisait et que ce soit pierre paul
jacques c'est un joueur c'est le joueur
des bulls joueurs y la norme paris ont
d'excellents joueurs
sauf que pour moi il hörmann que le
collectif que par exemple chester hier à
lui boire et eux ils auront donc je
pense quand même que pour moi déjà au
niveau de l'intérieur si on garde
l'entraîneur sûr on le laisse pas ce que
je dis bon entraîneur son passé celui là
il n'est pas mal non plus mais il faut
leur laisser de leur laisser le temps de
mettre leurs emprunts regardez les
autres grands clubs il a trailer il fait
pas il fait pas une saison il s'en va
c'est ça n'existe pas c'est pas possible
donc déjà rien que ça à mon avis il fait
déjà grand bruit
je suis totalement d'accord avec jean et
le constat est édifiant quand on fait le
comparatif avec manchester city qui avec
guardiola depuis plusieurs années et
guardiola a eu de nombreux échecs avec
manchester city mais ce n'est pas pour
autant qu'ils se sont séparés de
guardiola et on voit aujourd'hui que
cette stratégie est payante
c'est avec le paris saint-germain la
difficulté ces dernières années c'est
sur les entraîneurs dès qu' il y avait
plusieurs matches on va dire un peu
négative des performances négatives tout
de suite l'entraîneur a été remis en
question ça a été le cas dès le début un
dès l'arrivée des des qatari avec
notamment antoine kombouaré qui était
leader de ligue 1 et qui avait été
renvoyé c'était le premier entraîneur à
avoir été renvoyé sous l'ère qatarie
carlo ancelotti on connaît son palmarès
aussi dès qu'il ya eu deux premiers
résultats négatifs il a tout de suite
été mis sur la sellette et d'ailleurs ça
lui avait pas plu il avait filé à la
première occasion au real madrid
je pense qu'effectivement fo qui
solidifie qui justifie la position de
l'entraîneur paul chez tino est arrivé à
mi saison poitiers tino doit encore
rester sur le banc du paris saint
germain il faut construire avec poggetti
ne l'a pas eu forcément le temps de
développer toutes ces idées de jeu alors
oui on peut peut-être jugé son
immobilisme tactique sur les deux
matches face à manchester city mais il
arrive et il n'y a pas longtemps il faut
lui laisser le temps et lui donner les
moyens aussi de réussir peut-être avec
ce mercato il va demander l'aide des
renforts à son à sa vision voilà pour
pour renforcer l'effectif est au bout
d'un rang faut se poser aussi les bonnes
questions est ce que c'est vraiment les
entraîneurs qui sont les responsables
des mauvais résultats à des parisiens
le paris saint germain s'est remplace
s'est séparé à la une saison d'un thomas
ce tour elle qui est en train de briller
du côté de chantier qui a peut-être
alors où je vous parle puisqu'on
enregistre l'émission le jour où il ya
cette demi finale retour entre chelsea l
alma dry mais qui a peut-être se
qualifier pour la finale de ligue des
champions donc est ce que c'est vraiment
les entraîneurs le problème est ce que
c'est pas plutôt les dirigeants qui sont
derrière moi je pose la question
pierre chevallier si j'étais le
mannequin c'est l'esprit général qui est
qui qui change quand on compare
manchester city et le psg gagne 1,1 et
mot à ses juges je trouve dans le dans
l'édito du de l'équipe aujourd'hui
qui disait que les joueurs là les
joueurs du psg on en a suffisamment
parlé avec leur individualisme sont le
jeu ce sont eux le le jeu et l'esprit
alors que si on regarde un petit peu du
côté de manchester city c'est guardiola
l'esprit du jeu et qui est le garant
justement de ce système de jeu qu'il a
pu mettre en place
il a eu les moyens à la différence des
autres entraîneurs
c'est pas une question n'est pas une
question d'argent c'est une question de
temps que la dans le temps guardiola a
eu à la fois le temps de se mettre en
place plus les moyens de constituer son
équipe mais il a constitué vraiment un
noyau est une équipe autour de son
système de jeu le psg pour l'instant est
beaucoup trop depuis de trop nombreuses
saisons à faire valser les entraîneurs
et à ne pas trouver encore l'âme de
cette équipe malgré les nombreuses
individualités qui la composent
mike voulais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec simplement pour ajouté
ajoutez un petit peu sur ce que tout le
monde a pu dire il est fondamental
il est fondamental de laisser le temps
au coach de pouvoir instaurer sans le
nucléaire payant aussi les joueurs avec
leur big o c a eu aussi d'accepter ce
projet là et de ceux entre guillemets de
faire des concessions dans leur jeu pour
le bénéfique de l'équipe et mange pour
que le paris saint germain s'est pas
exactement ce sens en train de faire et
on a bien vu à travers les deux matches
est récente et une aux molosses et
peut-être aussi les dirigeants les
dirigeants besoin de soin de gagner donc
isolé normalement d'air france est vrai
et je trouve qu'ils prennent trop de
décisions rapidement ils ont peut-être
besoin de se poser de laisser le temps
au temps et un de laisser cette équipe
est loin des airs de far eu petits
réajustements au fil du temps mais mais
voilà de la patience et et que tout le
monde puisse vraiment se se fait semaine
dans ce produit collectif très
rapidement des griffes a rapidement oui
il ya peut-être aussi une forme
d'impatience parce que l'objectif du
paris saint-germain c'était de gagner
cette ligue des champions pour faire une
bonne publicité à cette coupe du monde
au qatar qui arrive en 2022 il reste
plus qu'une édition pour remporter cette
ligue des champions avant cette coupe du
monde au qatar
ben on leur souhaite en tout cas de
remporter la ligue des champions le plus
rapidement possible ils vont quand même
gagné 110 millions d'euros avec le
parcours en ligue des champions dont qui
pourront peut-être acheter de nouveaux
joueurs et au fait peut-être un petit
peu plus le banc voilà alors on
continuera évidemment sur l'actualité du
pg sur tb 78 et on verra s'ils sont
champions de france peut-être à la fin
de la saison
alors va maintenant passer à notre
deuxième thématique victor webb anyama
n'en finit plus de surprendre
à 17 ans seulement l'yvelinois passer
par le chesnay versailles a réussi une
grande performance face à gravelines
dunkerque pour sa première
titularisation en première division dans
le 5 de nanterre celui que l'on surnomme
le mutant a contribué à la belle
victoire des joueurs des hauts-de-seine
102 à 80 le tout avec un bien une bien
jolie ligne statistique 9 points 10
rebonds et 3 contres en 15 minutes de
jeu seulement
le sportif de deux mètres 19 va une
nouvelle fois attiré les regards des
recruteurs de la nbi et la question
victor webb
webb anyama est il déjà une star oui ou
non vous voter non pour vous vous êtes
partagés et non on va faire un petit pas
pourquoi vous êtes partagés pierre déjà
partagé parce qu'il est beaucoup trop
tôt de l'ue de pour le dire à ceillac
cessé il ya d'un côté il a un gabarit
hors norme
il est repéré il a il a des stats qui
commencent à s'affoler un petit peu mais
d'un autre côté il est 17 ans donc ccc
on en parle très souvent sur le côté le
côté éclosion éclosion de talents en
france on a la chance d'en avoir
quelques-uns peut-être un par décennie
selon les sports dans les sports
collectifs dans les sports individuels
mais mais n'allons pas trop vite en
besogne
lassé c'est vrai qu'on en parle de plus
en plus s'il s'agit de dire que c'est
une star parce qu'on en parle sur le
plateau de sion par les sports tv 78 oui
mais au niveau au niveau national
européen ou international
il a bien le temps de le devenir c'est
pas c'est pas pour autant qu'ils ne le
deviendra pas bien au contraire mais pas
encore alors pire ispm s'est intéressé à
lui ils ont fait notamment un reportage
un seul sur lui il parle de lui sur une
draft 2023 peut-être 2022
on ne sait pas mais ça serait sûrement
2023 donc les états unis s'intéressent à
lui un déjà ah oui et puis il ya même il
faut voir les il faut voir sur alors
c'est sur twitter les différentes les
différentes actions et différents traits
d et les tweets que le balance les
scouts de les recruteurs américains
et là pour le coup il est vraiment il
est vraiment dans les radars parce que
encore une fois son gabarit attire la
lumière
il commence à avoir des stats assez
intéressant pour son âge et oui il est
il est de plus en plus repérer et là et
savons sur le match on vous avait parlé
il ya déjà déjà un de recruteurs et
notamment des recruteurs vedette de la
nba qui ont fait quelques tweets et
quelques fred sur sur sa carte
ce qu'il faut noter aussi c'est qu'il
est il est désormais dans le cinq majeur
de plus en plus souvent
de nanterre et rose c'est un tremplin
alors c'est très très bien pour le
championnat
3 parce que c'est vraiment une mise en
avant du basket du basket français et sa
annonce un bond de très belles choses
pour ce pour ce petit garçon
en tout cas il est très observé un jean
oui voilà d'accord alors il y observer
il a 17 ans il a 17 ans il a des
commence à voir de belles performances
qui commence à voir de plus en plus de
temps de jeu dans une belle équipe qui
est nanterre en pro a
donc c'est très bien et moi j'ai joué
trente et une minutes 1 hier lors de
ceux de son match en 31 minutes pour 7
points 7 points hier sept points 9
rebonds et 4 passes
cette variante est elle juste poids très
justement voilà donc laissons lui le
temps de devenir éventuellement une star
et les seuls ça c'est le passé
alors là les jeux à la lame qui a des
bonnes statistiques et de suite c'est
déjà une star non resta il a rien prouvé
ou les stades c'est un espoir
j'étais le maire et sa vie que vous
savez que ça va très vite gens dans dans
ce milieu là et ça va très vite il a 17
à 20 ans avait déjà gagné la coupe du
monde
je suis d'accord il a 17 ans dit cette
baisse a fait croiser a effectivement ça
va très vite il est déjà réglé mais pour
les stars pour l'instant on vous parlait
de lui comme une star pour l'instant il
n'a pas fait quelque chose
sportivement pour dire ce qu'il veut ça
il a n'a pour moi il est bien parti
c'est un garçon qui a des qualités
physiques et techniques pour devenir
certainement car je vois mais ne mettons
pas la charrue avant les boeufs c'est à
dire c'est que l'esc le les eaux le lui
prendre ses marques et grandir tout seul
jeudi gras venir surtout les salles du
terrain dans sa tête comme techniquement
comme physiquement
bernard il a pas encore fini de grandir
je le précise en effet 2019 il n'a pas
fini de grandir médium et il a pâti
même physiquement il est encore après la
progression
donc moi j'aurais tendance à dire
laissons lui quand même le tas de
devenir une véritable star
il ay que je vous donne la parole
d'abord grégory laissons les jeunes
travailler tranquille c'était
l'inde est l'un des sujets des envolées
l'une des leurs des sujets de l'une de
mes envolé cette saison moi je pense
qu'il faut laisser les jeunes travailler
tranquille effectivement c'est un joueur
qui n'est ce pas indifférent de par son
physique il a il suscite l'intérêt outre
atlantique vous en avait parlé avec ce
reportage jsbn il sera probablement à la
draft 2023 peut être avant donc oui il
ne laisse pas indifférent mais laissons
le travailler tranquille et à ce sens je
trouve que pascal donnadieu le coach de
nanterre a été plutôt intelligent cette
année en intégrant progressivement dans
l'équipe
l'effectif professionnel de nanterre là
il ya eu ses deux titularisations en
deux matches pour pour lui il a aussi
joué des matches régulièrement avec
l'équipe réserve en nationale 1 donc je
trouve que l'intégration est plutôt
intéressante et il a une fracture de
fatigue qui l'a loué cette saison c'est
ça qui l'a éloigné des terrains deux
mois et là on voit qui revient bien donc
il est toujours dans sa progression il
l'aligné l'enchaînent les très bonnes
prestations mais il faut le laisser
travailler tranquille c'est pour ça que
j c pas une star encore parce que
j'irais même à l'encontre de ma propre
de ma propre envolée que j'ai fait cette
saison sur tb 78 mike qu'est ce que vous
en pensez alors vous le suivez vous le
connaissez bien
ce victor webb banias m'a volé ma soeur
on est en basket ont reçu sur mon sort
en société recommence après pour ma
définition d'une star c'est un joueur
qui établissent un joueur qui confirme
est reconnu par ses pairs et les
entraîneurs aussi aussi au mondial
moquant et qui en tient un impact dans
son sport mondial
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est un
garçon qui a une perspective d'avenir
incroyable de par son profil
de par sa mobilité de par sa taille et
toutes ces choses que les soutenir ou
cherche donc ce avec la mélamine
maintenant c'est un joueur qui a
commencé que cette année emploi a
commencé à faire des apparitions sur
quelques bons matches voilà il faut lui
laisser le temps laisser le temps de
travailler les points qui n'a plus rien
à grandir physiquement musculairement et
oui aussi mentalement donc
donc voilà il faut comme il a dit tout à
l'heure je pense qu'en france on a
toujours cette habitude de toujours
avancer la charrue avant les boeufs donc
les gamins voulait laisser tranquille et
il faut qu'ils aillent étape par étape
mais keylor comment il peut rester
tranquille en sachant qu'il a quasiment
sa place assurée en nba en 2023 alors
comme je le dis toujours pour l'unss
partie comme sur tout comme victor qu'il
ya une perspective d'avenir qui est
incroyable c'est vrai que c'est un
objectif au lit dans la nba
maintenant il n'est pas jusqu'à sion
dernier pour les pieds il est question
de vérifier pour les trésors du nord et
de par l'âge il faut déjà qu'ils
puissent dominé sur le championnat
français
après il ya le veau confit d'elle quand
on en parle toujours qui est important
les parents qui doit veiller sur la
bonne construction de leurs enfants
et puis laisser le temps de des prêts
pour pouvoir le guen dié et qui continue
à progresser parce que moi je préfère
des trajectoires plus voir comme tony
parker qui arrive au ndi qui arrivera
ndzié on ne tend pas du tout une star et
qui a construit sa carrière au fur et à
mesure et qui est devenue une grande
star et là tout de suite on se gare mais
l'antique singstar mais peut-être ça
peut lui mettre la pression ci est ce
qu'il est capable d'assumer cette
pression là donc c'est toutes ces choses
là qu'il faut voir c'est vous c'est l'or
jeudi les médias peut laisser ses
enfants tranquilles et aussi aux parents
de faire leur travail de pouvoir les
orienter et pouvoir les conseillers de
pouvoir les amener vers les bonnes
personnes pour qu'ils puissent elles
viennent dans leur thé et qu'ils
puissent bien conduire dans leurs
baskets ou à réussir leur avenir sportif
pierre chevalier est ce que vous pensez
qu'il doit encore travailler notamment
physiquement parce qu'on voit quand même
qu'il est assez fin mais très grand mais
à ses fins c'est ce que j'allais dire
c'est que c'est peut-être sur ces
physique un petit peu hors norme où
didier en plus qu'il fait pas fini de
grandir il faut il faut qu'on consomme
mais je ne sais pas quel est l'état
l'état de ses deux jambes ossature et sa
musculature
mais là il effectivement sur blessure
c'est sur ces photos là on voit qu'il ya
évidemment contrairement à moi il ya
beaucoup plus pris sous prix en hauteur
qu'en largeur 7 à fait injuste mais
c'est pas dur avec vous
une pierre mais effectivement il va
falloir qu'il sera entouré le petit
bonhomme parce que quand on quand on
voit si on dirait m des ailes et
peut-être même une fragilité les
fragilités assez remarquable et donc il
va falloir qu'il souhait qui ce qui se
renforcent sans pour autant verser dans
le bodybuilding mais le qu'ils puissent
en gros faire face à un jeu qui va se
muscler notamment s'il en est lié ça va
se muscler un sérieusement et se ravise
et même d'ailleurs puisque en plus en
tant qu intérieure il va aller il va
aller se frotter dans la raquette depuis
la fac il s'impose en plus de sa taille
donc oui il va falloir qu'ils soient
accompagnés et qui prennent un petit peu
plus classe tout en tout temps tout en
suivant une croissance semble il semble
assez hors norme
oui pour l'instant il fait 2 m 19 ans on
l'a rappelé 99 kg voilà pour l'instant
en tout cas comme moi sur ce concert
fois de comparer à zion williamson ses
120 kilos pour 1 mètre quatre-vingt
dix-huit si la nouvelle star un petit
peu de la bière vous confirmez mike
dernière question sur sur victor webb
anyama est ce qu'il est complet parce
qu'on le voit il peut tirer à trois
points aussi
mike oui c'est un joueur qui est assez
complet correspond fondamentalement au
jeu assez moderne de l'amitié qui est
basée sur l une des trois points et sur
la table parce qu'il faut que le dire la
nba ils ont changé énormément de règles
défensif donc maintenant c'est un jeu
qui est plutôt attirés vers la terre et
celle ci pour un jean kiffer 2009 qui
est candidat proposé c'est un avantage
pour lui après eux aussi posté il peut
aussi partir en grillage à une pomme
dextérité
maintenant tout ça c'est des choses à
travailler encore comme l'altitude à
leur pierre à se renforcer physiquement
parce que l'envié c'est noble et c'est
vraiment des athlètes avant
des basques d'êta donc je pense qu'il a
un ensemble de 100 joueurs à travailler
pour pouvoir être un joueur dominant les
performants aux états unis on va lui
laisser le temps en tout cas ce victor
au maniema on passe maintenant notre
page débats alors dans cette page débats
je vais tout d'abord passer la parole à
gregory kane aller pour son envolée le
moment que tout le monde attend à chaque
émission les apps et surtout pas vous
remettrez votre série netfix à plus tard
l'envolée de grégory est plus
intéressante que la saison 3 de kazan et
papel je vous l'assuré c'est avoue
grégory j'ai l'impression projet vous
parler aujourd'hui d'une bonne nouvelle
en tout cas quelque chose qui nous remet
du baume au coeur le déconfinement est
enclenchée en france depuis le 3 mai
étape par étape nous allons pouvoir
retrouver un semblant de vie normale et
cette levée progressive des restrictions
concernent aussi le sujet qui nous
passionne nous anime dans cette émission
le sport bien sûr est la première phase
a démarré le 3 mai reprise des cours de
ps pour les jeunes en intérieur levée de
la restriction des 10 km et fin de
l'attestation de déplacement pas de
grande révolution vous me direz puisque
le couvre-feu ray celui effectifs à 19h
mais tout de même on peut choisir ou
faire son sport et varier les plaisirs
poussé à vélo jusqu'à la vallée de
chevreuse terrain propice pour les
cyclistes aller faire son jogging dans
le cadre agréable du parc du château de
versailles ou le long de la bièvre
le choix est plus étoffé le 19 mai c'est
là que les choses vont commencer à
devenir intéressante avec un couvre feu
qui est décalé à 21h deux petites heures
de plus
c'est un petit pas pour certains mais un
bond de géant pour les clubs locaux
yvelinois qui vont avoir plus de marge
pour organiser leur programme
d'entraînement en fin de journée et
surtout la réouverture des enceintes
sportives au public
800 personnes dans les salles 1000 dans
les stades les travées vont retrouver
peu à peu de leur vie leurs supporters
qui les anime sans eau le le sport à mon
sens n'a pas la même saveur
la jauge je n'ai certes pas très élevé
dans un premier temps mais qu'importe
fini l'ambiance morose de ces derniers
mois fini peut-être aussi les bandes son
des diffuseurs qui a simulé un semblant
d'ambiance dans les stades est d'autant
que l'affluence n'ira qu'en augmentant
ça passera cinq mille spectateurs dès la
troisième la troisième étape c'est à
dire le 9 juin avec un couvre feu qui
passe à 23 heures on retrouvera donc des
créneaux d'entraînement
à 20 heures après le travail ça aide à
se vider l'esprit ça aide à se dépenser
à à penser aussi à autre chose de
pouvoir reprendre aussi le sport après
le travail en fin de journée et le sport
dont pourra reprendre en intérieur aussi
pour les adultes sans contact dans un
premier temps mais les contacts seront
de nouveau autorisés en extérieur fini
donc la pratique adaptée sans opposition
les entraînements ne se limiteront pas
aux simples exercices physiques et aux
passes je parle en présence de deux
rugbymen un basketteur et et moi-même
footeux on a quand même hâte de pouvoir
pratiquer notre sport
elles de manière normale alors toutes
ces restrictions seront levés
progressivement et jusqu'à la date du 30
juin tout cela si bien sûr la situation
sanitaire va dans le bon sens vous me
direz peut-être que je suis trop
optimiste que cette crise sanitaire et
de la manière dont elle va évoluer sont
trop incertaines pour se réjouir d'un
calendrier qui n'en est qu'à sa première
étape est les variants brésilien et
indien pourrait de nouveau rebattre les
cartes et re confiner le sport comme
nous l'avons l'avions déjà vécu en
octobre mais regoûter à cette vie
d'avant re pratiquer le sport à nouveau
dans des conditions qui se rapproche de
la normale même si c'est momentané je
signe tout de suite votre avis tout
simplement sur cette magnifique envolée
de grégory un je vous l'avais dit hein
c'est mieux que la casa des appels genre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
magnifique magnifique grec magnifique
magnifique envolée
et puis pour avoir brisé sport bien sûr
que le peu que ce que se réjouir que de
que ça redevienne à la normale mais
attention avec un petit bémol quand même
ça c'est un calendrier prévisionnel
oui voilà ne soit ne nous emballons pas
trop s'écarter un peu en tout cas voilà
mais bon si si et si ça si ça se déroule
comme ça ce sera très très très fière
déjà là depuis depuis lundi ont bougé d
un petit peu plus c'est déjà bien
maintenant il ne faut alors c'est pas
nous qui maîtrisera il ne faut pas
oublier un seul instant gars quand même
ceux de progression du virus qui nous
traîne et qui est attaqué au dessus de
nos têtes et malheureusement nous sommes
tous
bonne dame de ça donc là ce sont les
prévisions tant mieux vivre le sport que
le sport reprenne connaissait de faire
revivre le sport à toutes les
disciplines qui nous anime tous autour
de la table mais malheureusement j'ai
avec un petit bémol quoi il faut dégoter
être content être heureux être satisfait
et de l'autre côté être prévoyant voilà
bien sûr allié moi je met une très bonne
nouvelle parce que tout le monde sait
ici que grégory est un prévisionniste
hors pair mais quand on continue quand
il dit quand il dit par exemple que ça
peut être momentanée j'y crois en gros
ça va durer ça veut dire que ça va durer
et qu'on va pouvoir reprendre le sport
vraiment ceux ci il plaisante
réalisateur petites piques lisa part
évidemment
évidemment il ya sept ans passion qui
nous guette ça c'est quand même
maintenant plus d'un an presque il ya
plus d'un an qu'on est con on est tous
un petit peu confiné qu'on est con et
frustré de ne pas pouvoir pratiquer
normalement nos sports je parle même pas
des sports des sports d'intérieur les
sports indoor comme comme ceux qui n'ont
pas la chance comme les sports en excès
de pouvoir de pouvoir faire des
entraînements fonctionner même même
partiellement et donc de pouvoir avoir
7,7 ses perspectives de reprise pour les
rugbymans que nous sommes avec jean
évidemment on attend plutôt le 9 juin et
que le 19 mai parce que c'est ici la
reprise des contacts
il faudra alors il faudra le faire pas à
passer réathlétisation voir se
repréparer pour pouvoir encaisser un
petit peu les contacts et et puis et
bien évidemment en espérant que cela
dure parce que comme jean genet juste un
petit bémol en disant que pour l'instant
les chiffres des chiffres baissent les
baisses en chemin et il faudrait pas que
le porno
la libération collective des uns et des
autres sur le sport et sur la vie sur la
vie quotidienne nous ramène à des drames
est justement à des restrictions plus
importante mais en tout cas
évidemment comme tout le monde je voit
d'un oeil de très impatient et très
positif ce retour du sport amateur et ce
retour du public dans les stades même si
dans le sport amateur
une jauge de neil c'est un petit peu
surévalué mais peu importe
sadou ça nous redonne le goût de la vie
d'avant vous vous trompez un pierre j'en
attends plus tôt le 19 mai mais pour la
réouverture d'autres choses notamment
des terrasses 1 je tiens à le préciser
mais neuf jours ça m'intéresse aussi je
partage je partage aussi mike qu'est ce
que vous en pensez chiens n'ont que ce
serait dur de cette bonne nouvelle
apportée par an par grey après la
tension entre les armées indien les
parieurs anglais bientôt le vario
afrique nous avons très bien tout ça
mais sinon c'est une moindre envie de
retrouver cette cette vie en communauté
se partagent cette interaction avec tout
le monde et puis on sait combien le
sport il est important pour le moral
pour la santé
et voilà on a tous hâte et espérant que
que ne soit pas trop conditionné par
cette situation que puissent aller dans
le sens positif des choses parce que ça
peut maintenant déjà plus d'un an que ça
perdure donc mais est ce que vous y
croyez le 30 juin tous pas bon ça sera
ok on pourra encore reprendre
normalement sans souci vous y croyez
julien mike j'ai su seulement la croire
j'ai vraiment du mal à croire après
voilà on était tous optimistes parce
qu'on a envie de on a envie de voir
cette histoire là se terminer avec les
vaccins qui kiss qui se propage
maintenant et j'espère que tu me
reproches doit tirer mais enlèvement et
j'y crois pas trop que le 30 juin on
sera déjà on sera prêts assortis acteurs
sont aux commandes
pierre vous non plus après oui après il
ya les je pense d adaptation
les adaptations et le long terme sur
lequel on va devoir tout seul tous se
positionner je pense par exemple que le
port du masque va durer durer un petit
peu et si c est si c'est le prix à payer
entre guillemets pour pouvoir avoir une
vie quasiment normal et puis ne parlait
de ne pas le porter de ne pas le porter
en plein air mais lorsqu'il lorsque les
lieux soient un petit peu plus confinés
comme le comme les commerces les
commerciaux et les salles de concert six
sa séquence assez comment ça se fait que
on nous dit que si on fait des vaccins
les vaccins nous protège des phénomènes
de masse je pense que tu peux tu as tout
lâché en même temps et c'est le problème
c'est que justement quand on va ré
ouvrir des portes
il va y avoir cette envie de rattraper
le temps perdu et que je pense qu'il
faut laisser corée dans un certain
nombre de garde-fous et encore une fois
ci le si le port du masque par exemple
est là et ce qui peut nous permettre de
garder une vie presque normale jusqu'à
temps que on ait trouvé la solution
contre tous les variantes possibles et
imaginables ou un nouveau views je pense
que c'est c'est un prix raisonnable à
payer alors on est dans son palais des
sports patients par les sans terre mais
on essaye d'apporter quand même notre
notre analyse à notre à notre niveau
c'est bien moi je vais pas me prononcer
parce que voilà j'ai je porte la guigne
visiblement dans les annoncer dans les
pronostics n'ont jusque là indique
passage à la date du 30 juin
je pourrais y croire je peux y croire
parce que il ya l'été et forcément il
n'y a pas de match il ya les saisons
sportives sont arrêtés l'été
donc ça donne peut-être un sursis de
deux mois supplémentaires donc la date
du 30 juin de dire qu'on on pourra
reprendre la pratique tout à fait
normalement moi j'y crois je pense que
c'est possible en tout cas mais vous y
croyez moi peut-être pour l'automne
voilà ça reste ça reste à voir
l'évolution mais qui est incertaine
je veux pas voilà je peux pas me changer
en devint l'évolution est trop
incertaine n'a réussi à avoir le
pronostic de grégory sur cette question
en tout cas
alors si le sport se dé confine le
retour à la normale n'est pas vraiment
pour tout de suite on l'a compris la
course à pied paris versailles vient
d'être annulée pour la deuxième
année consécutive à cause de la crise
sanitaire les organisateurs ne veulent
pas prendre de risque en vue du contexte
et du flou autour de l'évolution de
l'épidémie
on écoute justement l'un des
organisateurs il était l'invité du 7-8
sport ce lundi 3 mai on a travaillé à
une compression d'euros maximum du
planning d'organisation sur 4 5 mois
sachant que la période estivale est pas
toujours et dante pour contacter
l'ensemble de nos prestataires et à
l'avancé sur l'organisation et on
s'était fixé donc la période de fin
avril pour décider de lancer ou pas
l'organisation donc ça c'était le le
timing on en ce moment et comme vous le
savez les incertitudes sur les
contraintes sanitaires pour les
prochains mois sont sont très très
fortes et ce malgré la vaccination qui
était lancée depuis le début de l'année
par par la france
donc voilà la situation est le point le
plus important est le point financier
qui en faisant pour être totalement
transparent beaucoup de plans de
scénarios financiers nous aller nous
nous engendré un déficit financier très
important qui allait forcément au béret
l'association et la pérennité de paris
versailles
alors on va récapituler chaque année
près de 25 mille participants venus de
plusieurs pays et 2500 bénévoles sont
mobilisés sur l'événement les
organisateurs donnent déjà rendez vous
aux participants pour le 25 septembre
la question sur cette thématique
l'événement se remettra-t-il de cette
annulation
oui ou non cette double annulation il ya
eu l'année dernière aussi
oui pour tout le monde grégory j'ai
l'impression que ça juste un petit bémol
un petit petit aparté abscons l'émission
c'est puissions parler sport mais plutôt
si on parlait annulation parce que à
chaque fois drôle de révélation ou
reports
on a des enfants on a parlé de l'open de
france de golf on a parlé également vont
signer bientôt la fin
l'open n'a pas de je pense que le paris
versailles s'en remettra parce que c'est
une institution dans les compétitions et
dans voilà ces événements qui font un
peu la rentrée en ile-de-france et en
france et j'ai envie de vous dire aussi
dans les yvelines bien sûr c'était très
difficile de maintien de paris
versailles qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire
et ce qu'il fallait maintenir le paris
versailles mais peut-être avoir un paris
versailles au rabais ou on parle
énormément de passes sanitaire mais on
sait pas encore vraiment comment ça va
être déployée on sait que le paris
versailles il ya vingt-cinq mille
participants vous l'avez dit ça amène
énormément aussi de participants
étrangers
est-ce que c'était faisable cette année
d'envisager un appareil versailles dans
des conditions normales et ce qu'il
fallait faire un paris versailles au
rabais je ne crois pas mais je pense que
ça reste une institution et que les
participants reviendront et il y aura de
nouveau de l'affluence dès l'année
prochaine avec je l'espère on pourra se
rapprocher d'une édition normale
j'espère que dans un an on sera sorti ou
en tout cas on aura la crise sanitaire
derrière bien sûr les organisateurs ont
dit 25 septembre 2022 il peut y avoir un
nouveau report en un pour l'instant en
tout cas c'est une date qui a été fixée
pierre chevalier 42e édition pour paris
versailles c'est un monument on peut le
dire de yvelinois c'est un monument
illinois et de la course à pied j'ai
qu'on ne vous surprendre je n'ai couru
deux fois 7 cette course qui a sa
particularité parce qu'elle était quelle
était votre temps du coup pour les 16 km
le temps était dirigée été mitigés ces
seize kilomètres c'est ce kilomètre de
jolies ballades comme on en fait
beaucoup dans les dix villes pour la
pied avec un dénivelé positif qu'ikea
c'est assez important pour une course à
pied mais pour récapituler voilà départ
de paris au pied de la tour eiffel il
passe par issy les moulineaux meudon
avec la célèbre côte des gardes chaville
vélizy viroflay ensuite c'est l'arrivée
à versailles devant devant le château de
versailles et dans les images dans les
images que l'on montre là je pense que
c'est la garantie principale de cette
course et que malgré deux années de
report ou deux annulations successives
avec ne parlons pas de malheur peut être
une troisième potentiel ce qui garantit
le l'histoire il a le fait qu'elle se
court en 2022 ou 2023 et qui a continué
à secourir
c'est justement le départ au pied de la
tour eiffel arrivée avenue de paris à
versailles devant le château qui sont
des monuments au propre et au figuré de
notre patrimoine français au niveau
mondial et comme c'est une course qui
est passé assez ramassé sur 16 km métier
et qui jouit d'une grande renommée
partout dans le monde elle doit pouvoir
se relever de deux annulations
successives d'ailleurs après le même le
même le l'annnonce de ce report de 2021
passe passe presque presque sans heurts
autour on comprend qu'il ya un certain
nombre de choses aillent et il ya eu
quand même beaucoup apparemment sur les
réseaux sociaux les organisateurs me
l'ont dit et beaucoup de gens qui ne
comprenaient pas est ce que vous
comprenez justement ces personnes là oui
oui oui
non je comprends pas ceux qui ne
comprennent pas il ya quand même un
cahier des charges à respecter c'est
c'est un grand événement il ya forcément
le thé les autres pour pouvoir leur vie
locale pour pouvoir le diffuser les mais
non mais on sait tous qu'on est dans une
position très particulière et c'est pour
reprendre le sujet qu'on ait évoqué
juste avant c'est que c'est que
finalement la vie la vie d'avant et la
vie normale va mettre un peu de temps
pour les éléments est selon les
selon les faits à reprendre à reprendre
son cours
mike qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
maintenant je pense qu'il a bien résumé
la situation après le ski est sûre c'est
comme lundi depuis tout à l'heure c'est
l'adaptabilité par rapport à tout ce
contexte cette conjoncture sanitaire qui
conditionne toute chose donc à prévoir
là il faudra de la tolérance
on sait que les instances les essaie de
faire le maximum
maintenant voilà c'est un problème
sanitaire que nous répète la patience et
les puits cinquième du sport forcément
ils revivront quoi pour ce pour ce genre
d'événement là je pense pas que l'équipe
que ça va ça va jouer et je crois même
que ça parce que j'ai regardé les les
frais qu'ils ont engagés seront
remboursés aussi mais dont les créations
sont remboursés à 100% tous les dossards
sont remboursés à 100% donc ça c'est
déjà une très très bonne chose donc
voila mail faut patienter et pierre et
puis voir ce qui va se passer ça m'était
ans qui servait aussi servir chevalier
c'est un petit clin d'oeil aussi par
dominique est c'est un petit ou un gros
clin d'oeil à jean marc trénel donc
l'adjoint l'adjoint des sports au sport
et de l'esprit qui nous a quittés qui
nous a quittés cette année
sa famille a pris le flambeau et
notamment son fils est un faux super
vite et ça aussi il faut le préciser
qu'elle perdure elle perdure à travers
tous les tous les épisodes possibles et
imaginables il même après la disparition
au regretté de gens c'est une course
grand public également
donc forcément le grand public reviendra
c'est pas forcément pour les
spécialistes
et bien sûr tout à fait c'est une
institution dans le monde de
l'athlétisme c'est populaire vous l'avez
dit c'est non seulement technique mais
c'est populaire et a beaucoup nous
granet qui se prépare pour faire le pari
versailles parce que c'était l'objectif
c'est serge lui allaient se veut un défi
c'était un défi de se faire le pari
versailles donc c'est une course qui va
perdurer et qui ont vaqué tiendra
toujours autant de monde puisque de
toute façon les animaux refuser des
inscriptions
donc quoi qu'il arrive et bien 25000
personnes tous les ans voilà voilà tout
à fait tu as fait et pour moi aurait
aucun souci se tiendra toujours et
toujours autant populaire avec plus
route à deux partis mais c'est quand
même là juste moi je voudrais juste
rajouter c'est quand même là pour moi
quand même sur l'optimisme qu'on avait
dit à l'heure sur la reprise normale des
activités sportives
là on vous passe à toucher du doigt le
bémol et la sécurité le pen de dire
ressemble cela va pas trop on est
conscient que peut-être
mais en alu et le paris versailles parce
que là c'est peut-être un petit peu trop
donc c'est pour ça que la reprise
normale des activités sportives
je crois que c'est par tweet est là pour
moi une sage décision que deux
malheureux malheureusement annulé cette
belle compétition et se passe sanitaire
est ce que vous pensez qu on aurait pu
très rapidement il nous reste deux
minutes d'émission est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils qu on aurait pu le mettre
en place les organisateurs disaient
qu'ils vérifiaient 25000 certificat pour
l'événement finalement pas sanitaire
c'était pas forcément plus qu'un
certificat grégory ce que vous pensez
que il aurait pu tenter le coup quand
même ils auraient pu tenter le coup oui
certes mais je pense qu'il y avait
effectivement trop d'incertitudes pour
aller de l'avant et pour maintenir cette
organisation retrouvons le paris
versailles quand il y aura de meilleures
conditions retrouve au le c'est une
course qui reviendrait ça a été dit il
et 25 mille participants hésiteront easy
seront dans les prochaines éditions
je pense qu'il est trop d'incertitudes
pour pouvoir maintenir cette
organisation et vaut mieux l'annuler
maintenant que l'annuler quelques jours
avant mais ça apaise peut-être les
tensions à pierre chevalier
oui c'est ça et ces essais sont de toute
façon c'est pour pouvoir justement
essayer de prévoir l'avenir est il que
les que les coureurs sont s'organise la
particularité de paris versailles c'est
que pour une course à pied c'est une
course qui est abordable et comme disait
jean reçu du monde tout le temps parce
que c'est c'est un défi mais c'est un
défi qui est atteignable
la preuve je devais donc donc cesser
c'est là aussi garanti que 16 km gens se
rappellent enjeux de la distance sur
cette distance là sur cette distance à
13 km et abordable pour tout le monde y
aura toujours des gens pour se mesurer à
ce défi important mais abordables c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
incitation aujourd'hui je vous propose
une citation du joueur de tennis borg
si vous avez peur de perdre alors vous
n'oserez jamais gagné je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]
oui